這絕對是最被低估的上漲訊號
只要看到這三根K線
接下來股價可能會迎來一波上漲
今天我要教你一個
都勝利的旗漲訊號
叫做紅三邊型態
這支影片你會學到三件事
第一
怎麼10秒之內快速判斷
紅三邊有沒有成立
第二
抓到上漲之後
什麼時候賣出才有最好的獲利
第三
我會教你避開99%的人
都會看錯
因此而大賠的現場
我是小王子
20年之生教育員
靠股票當充跟波段
連續五年獲利破千萬
紅三邊是有三根紅色K棒組成的形態
在講紅三邊之前
我們先快速複習一下K棒
K棒也就是幫某一段時間的股票價格變化
化成一根圖形
比如說日K
一根日K棒代表你價一天的走勢
它會告訴你事件是
開盤價 受盤價
當天最高價 當天最低價
受盤價比開盤價還要高
叫做紅K棒
代表買方比較強
如果受盤價比開盤價還要低
叫做黑K棒
代表賣方比較強
K棒中間比較粗的那一段
叫做實體
實體代表開盤價跟收盤價之間的距離
實體越長代表方向越明確
長紅K代表買方
把價格往上推的力道很強
長黑K代表賣方
把價格往下壓的力道很強
今天要講的紅三冰
也就是三根紅色的長紅棒
像這樣並列排在一起
這代表有人持續的買進
買方力道很強
接下來可能會持續的上漲
很多阻力在地點買進的時候
也會出現這種形態
但你要隨時注意喔
不是隨便逗別看到有三根紅K
就代表這個股票要漲了
標準的紅三邊有幾個重要的條件
第一 這三根紅K棒的實體要過長
我們前面講過
實體越長代表股票的方向越明確
第二 上影線不能太長
上影線代表股價曾經漲到這個位置
但後面又被賣方壓下來
如果上影線太長
代表上面很多人想要賣
股價就容易漲不上去
第三 這三根K棒的收盤價
也就是實體的頂端
要一根比一根還要高
這代表股價真的有持續上攻
最後一點 也就是最重要的一點
每一根K棒的開盤價
也就是實體的底部
最好要接近前一根K棒的實體
不能直接跳空
跳空就是像這樣
中間會出現一個空隙
這代表補價往上衝的太快
但我們要的是
買方慢慢的買進
慢慢佈局的形態
所以如果出現跳空
就要先排除
根據過去的統計
紅三兵出現之後
補價往上突破的機率可以高達82%
聽起來已經很高了對不對
但是如果再搭配下面兩個條件
勝率還可以再提升一個等級
第一個條件
紅三兵最好出現在下跌趨勢之後
下跌趨勢怎麼判斷
你可以看最近的股價
這是低於20日線
這條紫色的線就是20日線
如果最近有5根以上的黑棒
都在20日線下方
接下來股價開始跌訊長
並出現紅三邊型態
那很可能就是股價反轉往上衝的訊號
第二個條件要看成交量
剛才有說過紅三邊代表
有買方持續的在街
如果真的有一直買
成交量自然就會放大
所以紅三邊成交量放大
拆烤價值會更高
搞懂型態之後
大家最關心的一定是實戰
如果看對了要什麼時候進場
請收賣出
萬一看錯
要在哪邊停損
實戰的第一步
我們先把K線設定成日K
也就是每一根K棒
都代表一天的股價
因為紅三邊要抓的是買方
慢慢在佈局
持續買進
如果小於一天
時間太短
雜訊太多
大於一天
速度又太慢
會趕不上行情
設定好日K之後
我直接用兩個手段安利來講解
第一個
是今年年初
8046的南電
你可以看到
前面這一段的股價
很多都在
無色的20日下面
這邊至少有兩段可以進場的位置
給你3秒鐘
看你能不能找出來
3 2 1
公布答案
第一段是這三根
這勉強蒜蓬三邊
但這個實體太小
聽到不夠明確
所以我們不要理它
接下來網友看
這一段是很明顯的
三根紅K連續排列
實體也夠長
成交量也放大
看到這種不要猶豫
現在跟K棒就可以進場
買進之後
就可以看到補價一路往上漲
賺到錢之後
接下來就要找實機出場
我教你一個最簡單的方法
看5日線
也就是黃色的這條
如果股價低於五日線
而且明顯的往下彎
就可以先護利出場
如果你有抓到這段紅三冰
這筆操作大概一個率
就有33%的報酬
買一張短11萬
而且賣掉之後
每幾天這裡又出現一次紅三冰
又可以再抓一次進場的機會
第二個例子
我們來看一下停水
這張是6182的合金
也是熱門股
這裡出現了一組紅三冰
所以我們在下一根K棒進場
結果股價沒漲多少
開始往下跌
這時候請選擇要設在哪裡
答案是
第三根紅三冰的最低點
只要股價低於這個價格就要賣掉停水
像這個案例如果40塊進場
停數點差不多是38塊
灰鼠5%
但如果你硬撐不正賠
後面股價均勻往下跌
灰鼠就可能擴大到33%
這邊先快速整理一下紅三冰的實戰重點
第一紅三冰是由三根長紅可以組成
而且要一根一根往上
不能有太長的上影線
第二紅三冰在股價低點的時候
準確率會更高
也可以搭配成交用放大來判斷
第三跌破5支線的時候可以活力出場
紅三冰的最後一根K棒
第一點是停順點
接下來這段你一定要注意聽
紅三冰形態很好用
但它不是完美的
它有兩個很容易被忽略的缺點
第一紅三冰很容易被誤用
很多人看到三根紅K棒
就以為是紅三冰
但有些時候
那些根本不是上漲訊號
而是骨架準備反轉下跌的情緒
像這張圖
很多人一看就覺得
這是紅三冰
但其實這是陷阱
你看這邊
K棒的實體開始慢慢縮短
而且上影線很長
這代表什麼
代表買方塊要推不動了
而且上面還一直在賣
這種K線排列叫做
木日紅三兵
他在告訴你
骨架要反轉
要趕快跑
所以紅三兵看起來很簡單
但是如果只有削一半
很容易把下點
繼續看成上漲的訊號
最後反而賠錢
紅三兵的第二個缺點
就是它反轉速度非常快
骨架通常沒有走得很遠
過幾天
一兩個禮拜就點回來
你進場的時候
已經漲了三根K棒
如果反應開慢
你就會發現
才剛開始賺錢
隔定骨架
就開始反轉
所以紅三兵雖然很準
但是它的過曆空間比較小
你想用紅三兵賺到錢
核心只有一個字
快
你一抓到這個形態
就要快速判斷
趕快出手
股價反轉的時候
也要趕快獲利出場
但很多人知道這邊
會遇到一個問題
台股兩千多檔股票
總不能每一檔股票的點
來慢慢看吧
所以通常你發現
紅三兵的時候
股價已經漲了一段
你還來不及進場
行情就已經結束了
這個問題
最快的解決方法
就是用選股工具
縮小範圍
因為紅三兵很常出現在
主力準備拉台股價的時候
所以我們可以先用
智慧選股工具
搭配條件參數
找出最近組立開始有動作的股票
再搭配K線觀察
就能在第一時間更快抓到轉強的股票
像之前
在股價準備充的時候
第一時間就把它抓出來
那智慧懸股怎麼使用
條件又怎麼設定
我的免費直播講座裡
都有
也會給你分享
我最常用的
連結在影片下方資訊欄
你可以先點進去
不用花錢
時間到了 直接點進去看就好
如果這支影片對你有幫助
記得幫我按讚一下
有什麼想聽的
也可以在下面留言告訴我
我是小王子
我們下次見